nhưng mà không năm trong mật cầu, để để mở đảo.
Cái gì ở đây mà không về không đi ngoài gì nhé?
Điên sao, rất là khí kẻ là cái tức biến mở mở với kẻ, phải cầu,
thì đó đi mở gì lọc thì các cái tiếp biệm này cũng sẽ dụng theo.
Nhưng mà chắc các bạn sẽ lúc tổn tại một cái mặt phẳng cuy,
mặt phẳng đầy nó mà phẳng chứ ở các cái tiếp biệm.
Thế ra kênh chứ ở kẻ bà, tức biến mở mở bé mở xe,
thì mà phẳng cuy chính nó mà phá lý xe.
Mặt phẳng cuy nó phụ thuộc vào, thì chỉ có điểm mở gì động thì mà phẳng cuy gì động theo.
Nhưng cho nó có bụng đầy khoá lo con trọng như này.
Rồi đó, mà phẳng cuy, khi mở gì động như vậy thì mà phẳng cuy muôn đi qua một điểm của điểm.
Điểm lấy sẽ điểm mà gánh như sao?
Tế quá hết.